so you're arguing that the ambiguities
that exist in language would suggest
that that they can't possibly constrain
our thoughts exactly I think there's in
fact most of us don't even realize how
ambiguous language is and that's why
it's been so hard to program computers
to have a conversation we think each
sentence has a meaning you actually try
to program a computer to do it and the
computer will find 19 meanings and won't
know which one you had in mind but those
are really below our level of awareness
well in a way I suppose it's close to a
miracle that we can sit here and have
this conversation and understand each
other and thousands of people at some
other point in time are going to be
listening to some sort of electronic
representation of this conversation and
they'll know what we're thinking that
that's what that is astonishing then
people are just noises are coming out of
our mouths and we could be narrating the
play-by-play of a basketball game or we
could be talking about a soap opera plot
and they would just be slightly
different noises but human brains are
capable of unpacking the meaning behind
the noises to figure out in our case
that we're talking about language itself
but we could have been talking about
anything